こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
ヘラクレスオオカブトどうなってるの
第3弾ぐらいかなはい私今ここ700万円
で買った
各シェルターの中をヘラクレスオオカブト
の飼育ラボとして利用しておりますはじめ
しゃちょーですというわけで
ヘラクレスオオカブトのオスとメスを近所
のペットショップで買いましてそれが
2023年の5月の後半に買って
約2ヶ月ちょっとが過ぎました
ヘラクレスダホがどうなったかと言います
と結構バタバタと物が増えてきたりはして
いますがラボは一応無事でございます
ちょっとヘラクレス見に行きましょうか
失礼しますこんにちは
今日もかっこいいねイケメンだね今日も
[音楽]
いや本当に
背中がもうずっと黒くなっちゃったんだよ
なメスは土の中に潜ってますね23°c
適温今日も完璧な状態を維持している
ヘラクレスラボですはいヘラクレスは超
元気ですもう元気すぎるぐらい無事に生き
ておりますごめんね外に出しちゃって戻す
よで前回の動画で確か卵を産みましたって
いう話まで行ったんですけれどもそこから
さらに進展がありましてちょっと今どう
いう状況なのかを説明したいと思います
えーはじめしゃちょーの
ヘラクレスオオカブト
[音楽]
卵
現時点で70個産んでおります
子だから子だからちょっと待ってくれよ
70ってそんな
産むのヘラクレスってもうびっくりしまし
たで多分今の産み続けているのでこの
ペースだと間違いなく卵100個はいき
ます
100個こんなにうまくいくと思って
なかったんですけどもなんかもう交尾し
まくっててすごい卵を
産んでますそして
卵が生まれるだけだと無精卵と有精卵って
いう赤ちゃんにならない卵とかもあるん
ですよ
腰痛にならない卵とか
めっちゃ幼虫います
めっちゃ要注意ますもうびっくりする
ぐらい実はこの棚全部
幼虫です分かりやすいのとかこれとかかな
[音楽]
腰痛苦手な人ごめんね
これとかはもうちゃんと
幼虫してますねちゃんと幼虫してるとは
最近ヘラクレスやってたけどちょっと動画
にまとめてみたのでまずそちらをご覧
くださいどうぞはい7月4日に孵化した
幼虫です見てみましょうちょっと
衝撃映像かもしれませんねあれもどっか
行っちゃったあいたいたいたいた
もうこんなでかくなっちゃってどうすんの
これもう
[音楽]
これ結構指大きいんですけども僕の指より
細いですねすごい元気に動いてますねいや
すごいこれはこんなでかくなるのすごいな
マジで
命を感じるな一番早く卵から帰ったやつを
この大きい大きいワイドボックスに入れて
ますすごい横広なのでめっちゃ見やすいん
ですよこれだと動画に映しやすいかなと
思ってこの中で管理してますが今ちょっと
深いところにいるなこれだと見やすいかな
と思ってこの中に買っても部屋がこれ
卵なんですけれども現状ですよまだ産み
続けてるってわかんないんですけども一応
卵を今こうやって保管してますっていうの
をお見せします結構卵も帰っちゃってここ
に全部幼虫ゾーンなんですよ7月22日
に7月の27これが7月の28っていう
感じで
奥の方のやつとかね結構すごいですよ
これ7月の4日に孵化した結構早めのやつ
です
いやもう化け物系の大きさになってるよ
これとかももうすごいぞここからでも大き
さ分かるもんめっちゃ太くなってるという
感じでたくさん卵から腰痛になってるん
ですけれども
卵をどう管理しているかこういう感じで
管理してます6個7個これ卵の数ですまあ
いかに早く卵から腰痛に帰るかが分かり
やすくあもうこれ4時になってるねお
めでとうございますこれも幼虫になって
ますねカップの壁にね卵これで詰めておく
と
卵から孵った時にすごく分かりやすいので
こういう感じの仕方をしてます
めっちゃ湿度高めです水分超大事ですと
いう感じで7個の方も卵を壁に詰めてこう
いう感じで管理してますでこういう時も
バイトボックス超役立つのよね見て
ください卵を全部壁に詰めて管理してます
これでもうねどの卵いつ育ったかすぐ
分かりますはいこういう感じで全ての卵を
管理しています水分
びちゃびちゃです
卵マジで水分消毒らしいのでいかに湿らせ
ておくかが大事だと思います水滴
ぺちゃくちゃ
卵はだいたいこんな感じで今管理させて
もらってますよし行くぞ
多分こっちだなこの中にいる
傷つけないようにね手で煩わずに優しく
彫っていきましょういやもうすぐいそうな
気がするんだよな
[音楽]
あいたかな
いた感じあるぞ
救出だあとはこいつを優しく救出するだけ
うわでっかこれ結構育ってるな
ぁ結構
[音楽]
育ってんなこれこの子別の部屋に移動させ
ます行きます
[音楽]
ここに新しいお家をはい2
LDK一人暮らしには十分なスペース
でしょう
野生のカブトムシよりかはまあいい生活を
してると思います感謝していただきたい
はいこれで移動完了です見えるかないや
もう元気すぎていなくなっちゃったな
まあまあいいでしょうそのうち陽気沿いに
来ると思います
こういう感じでどんどん幼虫が増えていく
よっていう感じです
はいあと5個もあるんだぜがんばれよ一番
育ってる組ですねかなりでかい
[音楽]
はい8月14日ですまだ8月なんですけど
幼虫が
めちゃくちゃでかくなってました
もう俺の指より
細いですデカすぎんちょっと待ってまだ僕
ないんで今ねマットが結構踏んだらけに
なってきたので変えようと思ってるところ
なんですけどちょっと待って本当にまだ
潜らないで
撮影中ですよキャストの皆さんうわもう
結構でかくなってますね
腰痛苦手な人からすると結構もう限界
レベルの大きさだと思い
ます
はい他の腰痛はもうすくすくと育ってます
なんかめっちゃでかくなるのが早いんだよ
なここからさらに大きくなっていくの
でしょうかちょっと気になりますはいどう
でしょうかもうねすごいよ全部幼虫1匹
ずつ一応1匹ずつ分けて
容器に入れてます
これとかもう今腰痛になりましたね帰った
ところですこれが卵なんですけども
腰痛になってますねこれようこそわがラボ
へ不自由のない生活を保証するよはいと
いう感じで無事にヘラクレス
順調に育っておりますこれはねちょっと
楽しみです
卵70でこのペースで行くと100余裕で
行くでしょ100匹全部が幼虫になるとも
限らないんですけどそれでもかなりの数
きっとヘラクレスの成虫にならせたいと
思ってるんですよより一層気合いを入れて
育ててるんですけれども最近やったことと
してはそのヘラクレスの土ってあるじゃ
ないですか土これ見たらすぐわかると思う
んですけども土の色とか全然違うんですよ
ヘラクレスの幼虫って土を食べて大きく
なっていくのでどういう土マットにいるか
によってなんか大きさとか成長の仕方とか
変わると言われているので3パターン
ぐらい3パターンぐらい色んなマットを
使って
幼虫たくさんいるのでもう幼虫によって
違う土で育ててみたりしてますどの環境が
どの土がどの土があってるかどうかも
ちょっと気になってるので色んなお部屋
いろんな環境を準備して育ててあげてます
いやあのね
楽しいですこんなちゃんと育つんだって
思うからやっぱ環境なのとあとヘラクレス
ヘラクレスね強いわこの子達は強い
丈夫です
めっちゃくちゃ暑い部屋とか
めっちゃくちゃ寒い部屋じゃない限り
なんか
突然死んだりはしなそうな感じはあります
もちろんすごい気をつけてはいるんです
けどもこれはもうドハマりしてます僕は
卵そんなにペットショップでぺぺんって
買って育てたあの気づいたタバコだらけに
やってますからね今いやちょっとなんか今
おしゃれなラボっぽくしてるんですけれど
も物が増えたり棚が増えたりすると
格好もつけられないような気もしてるん
ですけどちょっと引き続き頑張っていき
たいと思いますなぜ皆さん無事です
ヘラクレス
成虫オスメス共に生きて卵を産みまくって
おりますただ幼虫期間すごく長いのでここ
からねしばらく幼虫が大きくなるのを
見守る期間にもなると思うんですけどまた
ちょっと大きい変化があったら動画にし
たいと思いますもうなんかめっちゃ見せ
たい
なヘラクレス
散らかしたいいやなんてね
幼虫何匹がいるしちょっと大きくなってき
てる幼虫もいるんですけど
結局ね生まれるタイミングがバラバラだ
からまだね大量の卵を抱えてるんですよ
でこいつら1匹1匹また幼虫になったらお
部屋お部屋を与えてまた並べていかなきゃ
いけないので日にちとか書いて結構
まだまだやることはいっぱいあるんじゃ
ないかと思ってますただね皆さん
[音楽]
楽しいもうめっちゃヘラクレスオオカブト
とか好きだったのでなんかこの手で
ちゃんと育てられてる実感がわいてきて
もちろんまだ幼虫ばっかりなんでこの先
どうなるかわかんないですけど最高に
楽しいですねマジの趣味になってますもう
ちゃんとこの子も生きてるのが嬉しいです
ね
お前の命は語り継がれるぞワンちゃんこの
まま無事にみんな帰ったら100匹近くの
ヘラクレスが生まれてくるという計算に
なるのでちょっとかなり
楽しみですすごくないこの部屋やっぱ温度
調節なんだろうな大事なのは引き続き
ワクワクしながらヘラクレスラボの成長
そしてヘラクレスの研究頑張っていきたい
と思いますじゃあな
[音楽]